and welcome back to the realist podcast
in the dunya
the three muslims you can see our very
beautiful sign
right above our very beautiful brother
masha allah we are very very proud to be
here alhamdulillah
for tuning in how are you guys doing i'm
the lord how are you
pretty good pretty good how's it looking
let us know what audio is how the video
is if everything is in sync keep in mind
though however insha'allah next week
july 1st on friday
professional edits everything's airing
you know no more uh of you know this
view that they see you everything will
be in sync and shut up look how clean
this is right here yeah this one look at
it look at the video
yeah it's it's damn the rest collection
that's clean man audio is great
gabriel romani
come on
how's it going bro how's it going
so when i gotta waste too much time guys
might be a lot of uh new viewers here
from uh who who am i talking about look
at this gabriel gabriel's giving a
spoiler bro he will just land it to you
guys soon gabriel bro
you you give him too much bro give him
too much
other way bro good to see you landed see
you soon bro um
a lot of people from matt walsh's
channel who is matt walsh matt walsh
actually i don't know what his
description is to be honest like that
he's been known as a as a transphobe
he's been known as a homophobe oh he's
been known as a misogynist yeah the man
the myth the legend doing work that most
people are too coward to do today
subhanallah got him but
matt walsh bro uh he made this
documentary called what is a woman right
it's it's almost like subhanallah after
so many years of civilization medical
advancement technology
no one can give us give us a clear
answer for that bro
and what's going on today is he made a
documentary
you know it's on the dailywire.com i
recommend everyone to go watch it it's
it's definitely it's paid but it's worth
it we've done it ourselves but there's a
little bit clips we're going to react to
today insha allah and uh smash the like
button please help the algorithm insha
allah ah
the enemy is going to be against us
definitely so so definitely
whose angle my man
angle my man you mean
this is the same brother that uh two
minutes before the live stream he's like
are you sure you're all gonna be ready
in two minutes okay come on now yes we
are uh i don't make a dice cap on deck
before we jump right in can you see this
video of course you can see it bro this
video got a 9.0 on imdb when i last
checked very hard for the critics but
rolling stone new york times
they've been slamming him without even
watching it i think that's unfair so
let's see for ourselves bismillah
for the first time in history
a marginalized group has a huge dollar
sign on the top of their head
we have five children's hospitals in the
united states
promoting that
[Music]
what that's a phallioplasty that's a
bottom surgery we have five children's
hospitals in the united states
telling girls
that they can be boys
at 70 000
a pop in a surgery that has a 67 percent
complication rate that will kill me from
infection that i can't sue on
butchering a generation of children
because nobody's willing to talk about
anything
i have three kids
at the age that they're doing this to
kids
i'm not transphobic
i love my kids and i love other people's
kids and you should too
this is
wrong
on so many levels
rami that was a biological what
that was a biological woman that was
actually a woman subhanallah
it's not allah allah is it's heartbreak
is he trans no she was a woman bro i
mean says
it was a woman that's is that not crazy
she's right she's saying nobody's
willing to talk about it
yeah
but we're going to talk about it we're
going to talk about it today
okay so what is what is going on with
this
you know
we won't say what it is because we're
not trying to get you know
d platform but
of the alphabet gang
the t's right
where did this all begin bro
i'm sure they've been watching our
videos this long
historically
recently recently in terms of this trend
of teas
well in the documentary one of the
reasons and we'll get into this in a bit
but matt walsh was saying
there's a lot of money to be made bro a
lot of money to be made yeah
yeah it did say that sex reassignment
surgery is a medical uh transition
extremely extremely good for making
money
very good for making money
and they are pushing those pills
the puberty blockers yeah supposedly
saying that there's no adverse effects
that if you got off of it your body
would just resume puberty
yeah i'm trying not to spoil the
documentary so much i'm thinking of all
these things that i learned from it and
i'm trying not to spoil it just watch it
it's true i gotta watch it trust me yeah
so sabrina wrote alfred kinsey she's
right but
it's it's all going with this
transhumanist movement that wants to
kind of change the creation of allah but
we know better so i don't know now
there's buzz lightyear bro there's you
can't even put put a a non-woke scene in
buzz lightyear
oh man this is a let down though we
wanted to watch it i was so hype we were
gonna watch it last night you
used to be my hero when i was a kid
and now it's back down to zero
yeah
damn i had a i have a scar
in the middle of my foot i told you all
this from when i was a kid
because i thought it was buzz lightyear
um
a lot all right we should talk about the
clip a little bit more all right let's
just analyze a little bit more this is
this was a biological woman who for
whatever reason you know
um felt within herself that she should
be a man or she is a man or whatever it
was and obviously the people that she
was surrounded by push this the doctors
that she went to push this
she has three children subhanallah and
she is basically suffering from a an
infection that eventually will kill her
as she says
because of
the surgery she underwent and everything
uh that was supported by doctors now
i think the biggest problem that's
something that she was highlighting in
this clip is they're putting this onto
kids
kids
and like not just like you know maybe
grade grade eight grade nine kids like
elementary school kids
that i saw one book
actually i think it was in the
documentary as well that one book where
there was a picture very graphic picture
and it's supposed to be a children's
book subhanallah children don't even
know
anything about sexuality about gender
even really to be honest they look like
you know they could see the boys or boys
girls or girls girls play with dolls
boys play with sticks and push each
other and stuff and there's a little bit
of the difference there guys are more
competitive and blah blah blah all that
stuff they can see that other than that
they don't know anything and we're
trying to teach them what
that
basically this entire encyclopedia of
not not sex but
gender and gender is not just man or
woman boy or girl male female it's
whatever you want it to be which is use
your imagination self-exploration they
use all these
amazing you know introspective uh
enlightening words
you know to veil this
gopher ideology
it's insane bro or osha is a gender
ideology
but uh unfortunately jordan peterson you
know i don't want to give too many
spoilers y'all better go on
dailywire.com and watch it but he got
the man jordan peterson himself on the
documentary and jordan peterson was
saying that there's masculine men oh
sorry masculine girls and there's
feminine boys
what about it
it doesn't mean you gotta go change the
whole creation now
yeah it doesn't bro
you want to go to the next one let's do
it inshallah
my name is michelle forcier
and i have a medical degree from
university of connecticut residency
university of utah pediatrics and i've
worked for a number of different planned
parenthoods for 20 years i do advanced
contraception and abortion as well as
gender hormones and sort of looking at
the whole sort of schema of gender sex
and reproductive
justice so you've done a lot of work in
this field could you just start by
telling us sure uh at what age can a
child first
begin to
transition into another gender or
identify themselves as
a gender different from how they were
born yeah well i mean there's there's
research and data that show that babies
and infants
understand differences in gender some
children figure out their gender
really early
and the reason why we are say oh that's
interesting or important is because
they're figuring out their gender
identity is not necessarily congruent
with their sex assigned at birth when
the doctor sees the penis and says this
is a male
has a sex of male that's an arbitrary
distinction
telling that family based on that little
penis
that your child is absolutely 100
percent male identified no matter what
else occurs in their life
that's not correct
have you ever met a four-year-old
who believes in santa claus
so this is someone who believes that
a fat man is traveling through the sky
on a flying reindeer at lightning speed
coming down his chimney with presents
yeah
would you say that this is someone who
maybe has a tenuous grasp on reality
they have an appropriate four-year-old
handle in reality that's very real for
them agreed agreed but santa claus is
real for them but yeah santa claus is
not actually real yeah well but santa
claus does deliver their christmas
presents
well yeah but he's not real though to
that child they are
when i see a child who you know believes
in santa claus and then let's say this
is a boy and he says i'm a girl
this is someone who can't distinguish
between fantasy and reality so how could
you take that
as a reality
i would say that as a pediatrician and
as a parent
i would say how wonderful my
four-year-old and their imagination is
male gametes that's what makes me male
no your your sperm don't make you male
then what does
it's a constellation in reality
in truth okay whose truth are we talking
about the same truth that says we're
sitting in this room right now you and i
no you're not listening if i if i see a
chicken laying eggs and i say that's a
female chicken laying eggs did i assign
female or am i just observing a physical
reality that's happening in the world
does a chicken have gender identity does
a chicken cry does a chicken commit
suicide let's reframe it because you're
talking you're trying chicken has sex
like any like biological organisms an
assigned gender
but a chicken doesn't have a gender
identity so we assign females to
chickens when they lay eggs we assume
they're female if they lay eggs one of
the drugs used is lupron right which
has actually been used to
chemically straight sex offenders got
him you know what
i'm not sure that we should continue
with this interview because it seems
like it's going in a particular
direction well you're a medical
professional i am a medical professional
so you don't want to talk about
the drugs that you give to kids or
again
i'm a physician and i use medication
you're choosing exploitive words
drugs i give to i'm choosing a chemical
word that was in a dictionary that's not
a correct term for puberty blocking i
could like look it up on my phone but
i'm pretty sure if i looked it up
you can look it up on your phone it says
medical definition the administration of
a drug to bring about a mark reduction
in the body's production of androgens
and especially testosterone and i'm
saying as a pediatrician who takes care
of hundreds of these kids when you use
that terminology you were being
malignant and harmful i mean there are
some who would say that giving
chemical castration drugs to kids is
malignant and harmful it's about the
context of caring for a child and and
seeing the
the suffering that kids can have that
have not been in affirmative home
situations
so we're going on this journey
boys can be girls girls can be boys men
can be women women becoming men
it makes me wonder
what is a woman what is a woman a woman
is someone who claims that as their
identity it could be many things to many
people
it could be many things to many people
guys
take your kids to your doctor when
they're sick this is who they're going
to be speaking to these are the modern
medical practitioners of 2022.
get yourself a muslim doctor please the
love on the legitimacy
yes please
oh my lord
i've seen this before but it's oh my god
it's like my faded memory bias just
doesn't want to remember i don't know we
watched this last week yeah that's oh my
god okay
okay a lot of things to unpack here i
say we go chronologically the first
thing that she was rambling about is
this whole thing about
kids having a gender identity at a very
young age
okay
oh no bro going to that because
you had a lot to say in our uh alphabet
episode
when a kid is young little boy little
girl
i just
just think that they don't know
they don't know i mean they
it's like you said they believe in santa
claus they believe in the easter bunny
they believe in like
spider-man
and superman and they think this is real
and then she's saying like oh well it's
real to them okay fair enough
but it doesn't change the fact that it's
not actually real
so if the kid now says oh like if a
little boy says oh i'm a girl
that doesn't mean it's real and that
that doesn't mean that a parent should
uh pretty much submit to that
and then the fact that when they start
getting older they don't actually need
the parents consent to take these drugs
i think that's
that's a bit much yeah yeah very
problematic
is this is this a live work for me i
don't know bro you telling me you told
me
[Laughter]
this guy
before we got to study medicine real
medicine
um
yeah so this is a biological woman from
what i know she's a doctor
a legit doctor
uh shout out to uh is a nara or nora
thank god i was born in a third world
muslim country
that's the dream
right but
someone has to speak about this being in
the west and
we're not we're not going to use you
know derogatory language or hate on them
or shaming types so anything like that
we're coming from a strict academic
scientific medical point of view the
same one that these degenerates think
that they're using we're going to use
the same medical terminology and point
of view uh they talked about lupron bro
i don't mean you want to go into that
this is a drug used to medicinally
castrate
uh let's say older people that like to
prey on younger people
this is what they're giving
pre-pubescent boys
to not start the journey and transition
into manhood actually i mean you're the
uh the more medical expert here but how
does that make you feel bro just knowing
that like let's say like you have a
younger brother
and he's young and he's like you know
he's going to school he learns about
this whole toxic masculinity you know he
sees manhood as something you know by
the way guys stay tuned for july 1st
inshallah first episode dropping we talk
right about that but manhood has
something taboo something scary you know
he goes on on the media and he sees
either a weak man or he sees a complete
evil vile toxic man he doesn't see a
good model of masculinity so he says you
know what i don't want to become a man i
want to stay a nice boy that i am yeah
let me take this drug and today the
passing bills that parents don't need to
give their consent and it's against the
law for them to do it what if this was
your brother man
that's hard that's completely
heartbreaking they talk about a case
somewhere in canada maybe vancouver or
something where um basically this
they've not forced it upon a young girl
but kind of force it on her father
and
basically there are legal consequences
for him trying to fight against it
basically which is absolutely absurd
because now we're living in a day and a
time where
parents have very little say in what
their kids will learn what their kids
are being brought in
you know what fantasy that their kids
are living in spanish but i find this
this trend a lot and it's really
important that we go to the root of the
problem right you're not going to snip
every branch of the tree if you want to
get rid of the tree you go to the root
you dig it out get rid of it right
the root of all this i mean if you look
at it we live in a very liberal society
um and and liberalism at its core is do
whatever you know pleases you
mainly physically right whatever pleases
you go for it and they have little care
to what is actually harmful
beneficial or truthful
that's why they allow alcohol that's why
they legalized wheat and a lot of not
just a lava promoter bro yeah yeah
including they sell cigarettes they
legalize weed in canada alcohol is cool
you know to these people even though
alcohol literally kills
alcohol related murders and deaths sir
you know honestly one of the highest
stats when it comes to death and murders
and so on and so forth and an accident
related yes and the dui is obviously all
these crazy things because they don't
care about what's actually healthy and
what they don't talk about allah which
is the harsh truth the harsh reality is
things like trans regret
are there not children out there that
regret the fact that you know they were
ignorant and these doctors put these
pills
down their throat essentially are there
not people like the the the woman that
you saw that looks like a man now
because you underwent surgery because
they were telling her that that's okay
go for it and now she is literally
killing her that we're not going to talk
about the people who un she talked about
you know do chickens on alive themselves
people
trans people unaligned themselves
because of trans regret because people
like you put it out there it's like no
it's normal it's okay they do it and
then they don't feel normal anymore
they don't because you're not basing it
in truth and she is the last thing i'm
going to say
she said whose truth are we talking
about
my truth is that you're a [ __ ]
that's that is what i'm going to refer
to as for now on because that's my truth
that's a fantasy i live in you're just a
[ __ ] right
intellectual subservient ideologically
molested miscellaneous
i want i want to i'm going to pin the
next person that can tell me who said
that
but um
there's only one
truth there's only one reality and i
understand words are a construct so on
and so forth
but when people say gender or sex
referring to
biology
it is not subjective it is objective and
yes i understand that there could be
there are different sexes it's not
straight male or female you could have
what is it x
x y or blah whatever
but if you look at the most rare one i
think it's what is it x x y as a
chromosomal disorder
the most rare one only occurs in males
so even then it's still you're either
male or female yes there's a maybe a
binary
you know in between some places
it does occur other than that there's
no spectrum there is no change and for
you to make it up based on
literally you just your imagination and
put that onto kids as well man it's
harmful see you can be a legit you know
hermaphrodite you're born with both you
could be a chromosomal hermaphrodite
like you know klein filters or any of
these syndromes where you have like two
x's and one y just like was saying or
one y two x's or just one x that's
possible too and you look at these
abnormalities
but they were made perfectly in the
reverence that allah has created them as
such
and i believe that allah has you know
allah doesn't make any mistakes and if
they were created as such khalas
we're not talking about those we're
talking about the people that were born
as xx or xy
and they're letting society dictate that
they should not be that way
omar jose dr omazed may allah bless him
talks a little bit about this in his
book he says that you know when these
kids are young right
they have different uh you know amounts
of androgens in the placenta right
basically where they're growing in the
womb
and these dictate on a scale and
spectrum according to his predominant
research as a medical practitioner as an
md these dictate where they fall
in a scale of masculinity or femininity
of being a woman or a man subhanallah
take that in
the amount of androgens or hormones in a
mother's womb dictate how masculine or
girly a boy is going to be or how girly
or of a tomboy a girl would be you know
this is what he did and conducted his
research so it doesn't mean that they're
a boy or a girl vice versa you know what
i mean
bro i can
i can explain this very easily and go
for it bro for people
right
we
as humans
go through
stages
okay
sometimes
when we're in the stage
we might think a certain way
might feel a certain way right
that passes and once it passes
now we feel and think completely
different yeah
not to air anything out but look at this
this is a tattoo
as muslims we're not supposed to have
tattoos i'm a reaver so i got this
before coming islam now
when i got this tattoo
i was very sure
this is what i wanted mm-hmm right
why
because that's just the stages
of the mental state that's right
now as time passed
i literally would look at this tattoo in
the mirror
and i would have this almost like
remorse just forget like what did i just
do
like i can never undo this even if i
were to get the laser removal i could
never fully undo this
and i would go back and forth back and
forth back and forth and i can guarantee
you everyone in this world who has
tattoos
has this well they'll go through stages
where they're actually oh i actually
like what i have and then they look at
it and they're like why did i get this i
made a huge mistake or something like
this or i should cover this up or
something right now what i'm trying to
get at with these tattoos this example
that i'm showing here myself as an
example
is that
i went against
the natural
inclination i went against the fitra
right so that's why there's this huge
regret you do something that's aligned
with the fitra there is no regret
you know what i'm saying so it's like
this whole transition truly
yeah yeah this whole transgender thing
and for people who don't know what fitra
is this is your natural inclination it
is your natural internal state the thing
that you are born with yeah
all right so if
again if you do something that's aligned
with that
then you don't feel this regret that's
constantly coming up
um through these stages that things
change but
if you do something that's against
then
let me touch on this point that rule
wrote because you know a lot of people
are wondering why why do food why does
food matter
i was speaking about this with someone
not going to mention any names now but
there are things in our diet there are
things
in the medications that we take the
prescriptions that we take these are all
to some degree greater or lesser going
to be endocrine disruptors today what
does this mean
your hormonal system that allah has
designed perfectly to not need any drug
subhan allah
to not need any of these enhancements do
not need anything right to modify it
there it's extremely sensitive bro right
women take birth control pills that mess
up their hormones for life
you know men take performance enhancing
drugs that change up their hormones for
at least a couple decades we're up to
science has proven this
if not just a few years and cause
permanently damage in in some way shape
or form in a lot of cases but what we do
know for a fact is when a woman who is
pregnant
is eating you know a lot of the things
today that have medications or at least
chemicals in the food right gmos
uh pesticides these types of things in
our diet in the water
it really does affect the developing
fetus to some greater or lesser degree
and that's a leading cause of what's
going on with
uh you know these birth abnormalities
and the androgens and the hormones and
it leads to a bunch of these kids
growing up either as masculine girls or
feminine boys and it's one of the
leading causes bro but it's profitable
right so why talk about it big pharma is
one of the biggest culprits between
behind this behind uh the alphabet
movement behind the sex reassignment
thing
extremely disturbing bro
yes
one last thing i want to say to kind of
piggyback off what brother angel said is
um subhanallah there are some things
that we just we shouldn't be allowed to
choose bro we shouldn't be allowed to
choose some things
if allah decides you're going to be a
male or a female
like
you don't have the right to choose you
don't you know i don't you don't you
don't get to choose anything really you
don't get to choose your ethnicity you
don't get to choose your skin color you
don't get to choose what you know class
you're born into if you're low class and
middle class if you live live in a first
world country third world country and
sex gender whatever you want to call
just one of those things you you just
can't choose and khalas like
if allah gives you something
who's more wise you are allah
allah is more wise
even even even if you for some reason
disagree
you can't actually change it that's i
think that's the worst part about it you
will never actually change it
effectively you can only try your
absolute hardest i think that's why a
lot of people have this trans regret
because a man will look at a woman and
be like i'm going to become that you
will never be that you will only pretend
you are until you get hit in the face
with the reality that you're not and
then it's going to hurt bro and then
you're going to fall into trans regret
well it's scary read this book that's
harsh
well we got to read it out loud some
people are listening on spotify male 1
bless them so sonia writes i'm an ex rad
femme
you guys know that is and an anarchist
in some sense and i have seen madness i
was close to being analysts because of
this gender ideology it made me
depressed so i turned to religion
mashallah
may allah bless you
i mean i mean but man
it's crazy bro
these these people who will go through
this what you just said man
like bro they're gonna get to the point
where they do regret it and by that
point it's too late bro yeah you can't
go back like if
if you were a man
from the beginning
and you ended up chopping
yeah
people say pp
can can we say this online no no just
say pee pee bro
pp
you say it bro you're gonna get this so
you're gonna get this whole thing d
platform bro
we're this close guys we are this close
to be completely booted off all social
we've already gotten banned from patreon
and getting
can i say it in spanish no
come on bro come on bro you got a lot of
you got a lot of youtube geeks bro in in
mexico that are that are trying to block
channels left and right they're going to
see they're already coming for you bro
subhanallah we can't even say the word
guys cucumber they cut the cucumber off
they're cutting the cucumbers and once
they don't have that cucumber no more
and they realize what the
hell did i do
yes too that you can't get that cucumber
put back on i'm sorry
um
and scissors sonia if you want to write
down any of the changes that if you're
still watching any of the changes that
you've gone through and lessons you've
learned along the way after you've left
these
weird man-made ideologies just to
destroy men and women and humanity as a
whole in ummah
and what you've kind of learned after
you revert it back to your natural
inclinations mashallah let us know yeah
bro we need we need this one we need to
use the call in function we definitely
need to use the calling function yeah
inshallah okay cool aside from that
we're going to go right into the next
video bismillah smash the like button if
you made it this far
hashtag cucumber so we know we made it
this far
get ready for some madness guys
we're talking about gender and sex and
there's a lot of controversies there if
we're talking about a trans woman has
all of the male
physical characteristics so would that
not be
a male then couldn't we plainly
say this person is a male well well i
guess it's like
why are you asking the question i think
i i want to understand sort of why
that's so important so if someone tells
you to
sort of understand
reality
you know
well i mean i think when someone tells
you who they are you should believe them
so if a person says that they're a woman
or they're a man then that's them
telling you their gender is i'm not so
sure why what social um
interactions would have to do with with
maleness or femaleness that i'm not even
talking about social context i'm just
i'm just trying to start by getting to
the truth you know
yeah i mean i'm really uncomfortable
with that language of like getting to
the truth again in social life why is
that uncomfortable because that it
sounds actually deeply transphobic to me
um
and if you keep probing we're going to
stop the interview i if i probe about
what the truth is you keep invoking the
word truth which is condescending and
rude i'm saying to you how is the word
truth kind of sending a root
why don't you tell me what your truth is
and you're walking on 30 seconds more of
the nights before i get up
what my truth is well i don't think i
really have a truth i think that there's
just
the truth
like the reality
and so
we should begin by trying to figure out
what the reality is
uh-huh and why are you concerned with
when someone else tells you that they're
a man or even if they use the word male
why are you concerned with not believing
them
well you keep bringing it back to you
know how do you respond in a social
situation that's what i do i'm a social
scientist well right but we're in a
university this is a place of
understanding truth isn't it or
absolutely we pursue the truth and i'm a
social scientist and that's what i do
you just said the truth is transphobic
that you would say that you're if you're
saying the truth is that i get to say
you're not a man show me your genitalia
that's transphobia no i don't want to
see him as genitalia i i just mean
someone can make a statement about
themselves that could be untrue like for
example if i
if i were to say that i'm a black man
could you
would you accept that or would you be
skeptical
are you black are you afraid of american
are you racial wow
why are you kidding so well you don't
look that and i don't think that's a
that it doesn't sound like that's a
genuine statement of who you are
okay so that's my point i could make a
statement about who i am that's
incorrect
of course i think it's well established
that human beings can lie yes
or not even lie i mean i could just be
mistaken
[Music]
i guess this all comes back just cause
it's all comes down to really one
question
um especially
women
gender and sexuality studies
so what so what
what is a woman
why do you ask the question
i just really like to know
what do you think the answer that
question is
well i'm i'm asking that's why i came to
a college professor dude because
this is your this is what you do
what other kinds of answers have you
gotten look at his body language getting
closed
a lot of like this where you're not
answering i've gotten a lot of that so i
think it's interesting that you that you
say that some of the people you've
you've um interviewed have been i'm
reluctant to answer it and i think that
has a lot to do with the way the
question guys listen i'm sorry for the
zoom ins bro i just had to when i was
editing
i got to see that one more time bro
[Laughter]
you've um interviewed have been
reluctant to answer it and i think that
has a lot to do with the way the
questions that preceded it and the way
that you've conducted yourself in the
interview how have i conducted myself
how do you think you've conducted
yourself
you just really don't answer the
questions do you
i came today very willing and
enthusiastic about answering questions
about women and gender sexuality studies
which is so you wanted to do you wanted
to answer questions about women's
studies and so
the first
answer you should be able to provide is
what exactly is a woman well it's it for
me it's it's actually a really simple
answer and that's a person who
identifies as a woman but what are they
identifying as as a woman
what is that
as a woman
do you know what a circular definition
is
i do
it's sort of like what you're doing
right now where a woman is is a woman
because you're seeking what we would
call in my field of work an essentialist
definition of gender i think it sounds
like you would like me to give you a set
of biological or cultural
characteristics that are associated with
one gender or the other i'm not seeking
any type of definition i'm just seeking
a definition yeah and i gave you one
well now i can say i've been to college
[Laughter]
oh my god
we should get someone to analyze
everything what he was saying the body
language and just completely break it
down
i don't think you need to be an expert
we don't need to be an expert to do that
but what i found profound guys is
the hypocrisy between
the first thing
this
man i said
that i'm even calling that
if someone tells you they're a woman you
should believe them
contrast that with i don't believe it's
a genuine statement that you're black
why
why why do you have an issue accepting
that he's he's black
yeah
if they look like a man but they say
they're a woman we should believe that
sure yeah then if they look like a
five-year-old and they want to go after
a five-year-old girl you should believe
that
where do you draw the line
and again something you notice about
this interview again is is the whole
notion of truth he brings it up matt
walsh brings it up a lot and they always
respond with
this kind of you could see the cognitive
dissonance you can see how frustrated
they're getting because it's kind of
like you know imagine i make a
a reality for myself right i'm a
blue-pilled guy i make a fantasy world
for myself where i'm like
um an astronaut and a doctor and a
musician and i mean this haram you know
akari and all these amazing things and
someone comes and they're like listen
you're none of those things like where's
your credentials let me hear your quran
all of a sudden i start getting angry
like cognitive dissonance because
they're breaking apart my fantasy
because it's not the reality it's you
know i'm waking up to the hak i'm waking
up to the truth and it's a very the
detestful if that's a word feeling right
so obviously no one would like that you
could see it with these people it's so
sad these are our medical experts these
are doctors these are professionals and
this is how they're conducting
themselves
two questions here that i want you all
to answer me bro why don't you take a
spin on it
could we possibly see matt walsh on the
podcast
i'd love to ask him why he's still a
christian because if he has an open mind
let's talk about some stuff
you know
next question bro
i can't see okay so brother ben ekra
writes salaam guys have you looked into
using obs for your streams instead of
streamyard the reality is uh brother ben
i say this in in the most loving of
intentions that this will be our
last live stream
not forever
but for a while
because we are switching over to
professionally recorded
uh episodes podcasts inshallah
editors uh multiple angles all that
they're pre-recorded they're not gonna
be live anymore and they're gonna start
next week on friday insha allah july 1st
2022 you are going to get fresh new
podcast every single friday so no more
of these live streams anyway so
inshallah you'll get good production
quality not just you know lighting like
this where it's just getting it done for
the podcast inshallah
okay we got two more clips to react to
uh anything else on her
you didn't really weigh in on this this
clip much
on this clip yeah
it just goes to show like these people
they uh
they want to be right
so bad
hmm
you know like as as muslims
if we are not right and we are corrected
and it's like okay
you know like or if we have no idea what
we're talking about we're like look like
i just don't know we don't know you know
like let me let me
give you the information from someone
who does know
right we we don't try to
um put up this front but that's what you
see these people doing all the time
is they're putting up this front they're
trying to say like
that this is what it is one clearly it's
not and then when they're questioned
about it they get defensive like romney
said cognitive dissonance
but then it's also like their ego is
like no like we have
we have to be correct like we have to
stay on this
in whatever way shape or form we can so
um
it's just it's dangerous bro it's
pathetic yes i want to read some of
these comments bro
i miss you guys hello mars bro
you got on the podcast a couple months
ago
yeah bro
you still using that uh facial cleanser
at night
martial
next we got brother moed will you be on
spotify not only will we be on spotify
we've been on spotify since we started
this podcast about a year ago since
episode one uh just searches up the
three muslims one word just as it is on
youtube inshallah you will find us we're
on apple as well soundcloud google
podcasts so many so many platforms okay
last one
i identify as a billionaire where are my
billions you bigots
but a few billionaires show us the money
that was the money boy
just to show how funny it is because
this is actually what they do you know i
comment i say i'm a billionaire you're
like show me your bank account show me
your billions i'm like what do you mean
why would i need billions of dollars to
be a billionaire
i'm a billionaire he's like well what is
a billionaire it's a billionaire
okay but what is it it's a billionaire
it's like show me billions like i don't
need to have billions of dollars to be a
billionaire but i'm a billionaire that's
exactly what they are doing
yeah
let me let me let me bring that up
actually you know what you guys already
seen this you can rewind it if you want
in your free time but basically that's
what that man was saying what is a woman
someone who identifies as a woman what
is that a woman what is that a woman
like bro
you got ovaries you got an x and a y
chromosome
you got a vahivahi down there
i'm trying so hard not to be a giant me
too and that makes you a woman bro
that makes you a woman is it that hard
to say bro
your son comes to you bro and tells you
he wants to be a girl he feels like a
girl what do you say
all right bro hey let me get you this
dress let's paint your nails bro and
let's let's go to school bro go like
that let's see how you feel probably
ashamed
actually society would love that they
call that gender affirmation yes yeah i
can't even say that i can't even say
that bro
you can't even be sarcastic bro nowadays
facts around me
you guys need to start a halal fight
club
it feels like a
contradiction in terms
below writes always i really always
learn from this channel
no they're talking about like the movie
you seen it
yeah it's not talking about like a mma
club
it's like
well i can't speak about it
that's possible but one of the rules of
fight club is you can't see if you can't
speak about it let's do the last clip
inshallah this is not directly from
the
documentary but this is something i want
to kind of comment on
of course i have been covering the uh
wonderful month of pride for which i
feel no pride for at all i think it
should be called shame month it's
absolute debauchery um but you should
know that over two hundred thousand
dollars is being spent on drag queen
shows at new york city schools
why
i don't know i i'm not sure why drag
story hour in new york city need needed
46 000
injected from city contracts for
appearances at public schools and street
festivals and libraries why does that
need to happen
i don't know maybe it's because it's
very obvious that there is an agenda on
our children and they keep trying to
tell you that you're homophobic if you
talk about it but it's not homophobia to
talk about the fact that they are going
after our children i have said on this
show and i have been mocked for it that
it's very obvious that pedophilia will
be around the corner right there's no
reason that we should be seeing images
of children putting dollar bills in half
naked men that are dressed up as women
and seeing adults applaud it around as
oh this is love love is love love is
love by the way that is one of the
dumbest expressions i've ever heard in
my love is love air is air air water is
water it's stupid debauchery is
debauchery and that's what we're looking
at right now our society has become
increasingly disgusting i spoke about
this last week and when when you believe
when you start to see that your
government is sponsoring that when
they're putting real dollars behind
things like drag queen story hour in new
york city you should realize that
something nefarious is going on because
the government does not care about your
children no the government does not love
your children the government does not
want your children to be accepted the
government wants your children to be
enslaved to government for the rest of
their life and right now as we're seeing
there is a marriage between government
and big pharma is my belief that that is
the push behind this effort to tell
children that they can pick their gender
and to confuse them i believe our
government is actually sponsoring mental
illness i've said this over and over
again right because people that are
mentally ill cannot stand up on their
own two feet right they become
codependent with the government they
turn to the government for their hormone
pills they turn to the government for
whatever pills they can to make it feel
better right and you are seeing right
now that adults are getting behind this
narrative so that they can have a woke
t-shirt on and say i love my children i
allow my child to pick their gender and
pick their species and they feel proud
of themselves because they can go and
they can say this on facebook that
they're a wonderful accepting and loving
adult when in reality they are under
qualified to have children they should
have their children taken away from them
because it's child abuse it is child
abuse to put a half naked adult in the
room with a small child and having them
read a book it's just child abuse that's
what it is it's child abuse do you ask
your your child to take a dollar bill
and put it into the thong of a grown
adult it's childhood it's child abuse
for teachers to be telling children
knowing fully well that it is a lie that
they can switch their gender
biologically right but to encourage that
behind a parent's back that's child
abuse so the question remains is when
when do parents draw a line and start
realizing this start realizing that the
scholarships and the nice schools are
not worth all of this it's not worth
allowing your child to be abused by
mentally ill adults
and we don't identify and agree with
everything else
that
far-right extremists like candace owens
i'm gonna say it as it is extremely
pro-neo-conservative
politicians we don't agree with them in
everything
but what we will say is when it comes to
preserving conservative traditional
values
religiosity even though some of them
follow some corporate ideologies but
religiosity as a whole principles the
family unit the family structure saying
no to abortion saying no to drugs saying
no to big pharma saying no to alphabet
gang
the conservatives got it right
for now because who knows what's going
to happen tomorrow and candace is right
bro subhanallah they're manufacturing
mental illness because mental illness is
extremely profitable and a state that is
mentally sane will not bring uncle sam
a single dollar
that's what i think the biggest problem
lies
is the mental illness component
because we
we all got issues
if you think about it
you know like yeah we might not go out
here like blatantly like throwing it out
they're like yo i got anxiety bro
nah like we all got things going on in
my head of course and then like if
some people they actually
um they take it too far they start
thinking about it too much and they
start identifying with it and then
that's when it like consumes their life
that's when they start taking medication
they start going to doctors it's like
running a psychologist and all this
stuff and it's just like i said it
consumes everything then you have people
who get past it right so this whole
thing about like
thinking
you're a girl when you're actually a guy
or thinking you're a guy when you're
actually a girl like listen this is um
it's another case it's it's exactly the
same as anxiety
and um
an example i want to give you this
person that i know uh this dude used to
paint his nails
he used to paint his nails and i would
ask someone's like
bro what is that like what the hell is
on your nails right now
and then he's like oh i painted my nails
i'm like yeah no i know that's that but
why is that on your your nails like you
you're a man like why do you have that
on your hand
he's like oh bro like it's all right
like it's not a big deal and i was like
are you kidding like it's
are you serious bro like listen
why don't you go to jail
and then paint your nails
and see how the see how the other men
treat you in jail bro
they're gonna pull their pocket out and
be like here grab on to this buddy like
you're mine
and they they're gonna say very clearly
and it's sad but it's like he said i
said that to him and he started laughing
i was like no bro this is very serious
like you're over you're paying your
nails like this is not normal a man
should not be painting his nail then he
tried to say that he was customizing his
character
it's like customizing your character you
can't do other things you can't you guys
can look on your your wardrobe
or some nice fits or some nice shoes
yeah you got to paint your nails
and he tried telling me about this uh
friend he had and this friend he had was
um
[Music]
i don't even remember the name even if i
did i shouldn't say
but he said the name and i was like
um that's that's a guy no i said that's
a girl right
and then he's like no no no it's not a
girl and then when i see i'm like oh
it's a guy he's like no it's not a guy
i'm like
what is it then
and he's like uh it's it's it's an
it
it doesn't define as any of the genders
i'm like oh damn brother here we go
how do you guys feel about your future
kids growing up with these societal
norms truth be told
i will still have kids i will never be a
black color who says i'm never going to
have kids i give up on this because of
the state of society because 10 15 years
ago we could have said the same thing
because that hey the world hates muslims
i don't want to bring kids into this
you know uh five years ago when this
whole uh radical femme movement started
you know spreading like a carcinogen we
could have said hey i don't wanna bring
kids because they're going to neuter my
boy
and they're going to radicalize my girl
15 years from now in the future who
knows what could happen bro there's this
thing called trans age and trans species
and trans race okay
trans race is absurd we've already
reacted to it right
trans age is a little weird they're
pushing the the touching the children
narrative
but trans species is just something else
remember that that wolf on the movie we
watched
what is a woman in the documentary there
was there's a guy identifying as a wolf
yeah
where do you like it's funny anna's
trying not to laugh but bro where do you
draw the line and and the thing is bro
it's only going to get worse this was
prophesied by the prophet of islam
this was
foretold by a lot of even secular
individuals that are that are geniuses
of their time
and just look at the trajectory was
going
you you don't want to have kids and this
is not you know talking to brother moaz
this is just in general people saying
faith in humanity lost i don't have kids
if you don't want to have kids
then there's going to be these idiots
having kids
and teaching them kofor ideologies and
all this bs
where do you think that's going to go
rather we should have more kids and
teach them proper values
yes inshallah our kids should be the
leaders of the next generation you
should have kids in sha allah with the
goal that this person is going to spread
islam and give dawah and bring many
people to islam insha allah
you know imagine if like you know
like mohammed hijab's parents were like
oh i don't want to bring their son into
this you know this generation or
something you know
but i have the brother
you know so
inshaallah just uh
have a good intention have a good night
insha allah will uh take care of the
rest
tunisian tunisian homeschooling um not
what romney said but the commentary um
and i think this is where we should give
a big shout out to ferraza hobby when we
had him on the podcast
and like he's clearly putting his kids
in school but he's also clearly like
in
the kids and lives and like really
explaining things to them like look this
is why we believe what we believe yes
you know and that's the most important
part because we can't we can't
completely
um
veil them and like hide them from
society because at some point another
they're going to be in society so
they're going to see it for what it is
so why not let them experience that but
also show them like look this is where
the problem lies this is where there's
the fault this is what it actually is
exactly that's what the brother montage
was writing just be good father's people
and you should prevent this
inshallah
if you guys don't know the clip that
brother ana was talking about type up
the three muslims clips this is our
second channel on youtube and it's one
of the most viewed videos subhanallah
this got on news articles this guy on
websites and magazines this podcast that
we did with zahabi but this specific
clip so inshallah don't miss out on that
i think we should do the q a then wrap
up yes insha allah okay guys important
questions let us know
uh and inshallah we will wrap this up
that was quick boy it was quick an hour
just passed by
okay first one wrong here i'll let you
do it
a game individual i know from college
said the world started to go down in
2015.
i told them that it correlates with gay
marriage being approved in the u.s and
he denied it
slippery slope is real
well it's not a question though
okay we got we got a couple questions
now you asked for it bro
do you guys know
japan banned some same-sex marriage
recently
good martial yeah
vocalism is a disease that needs to be
eradicated 100
okay brother rami
how do you respond to people who say why
don't you move to a muslim country if
you don't agree with the west
i mean you say that like muslim
countries actually how like sharia law
and their property bro go to dubai
they're the most western they're more
western than the west bro in dubai
saudi you know subhanallah i won't say
anything about them but yeah they have
nicki minaj concerts and stuff like what
am i what am i going there for
subhanallah
and half the bro half the middle east is
torn up
yeah
and think about it too like
if you're in a muslim country
the dawah opportunities is
far less because supposedly supposedly
the entire environment around you is
muslim yeah you know so like who do you
give dawa to that's true that's true
you're about to write is there really a
difference between homophobia and being
against the ideology so
phobia
psychiatrically speaking is a fear of
something medically right yeah they've
used
phobia here as a political term of just
saying you're against the ideology
are you scared of gays if if
if you don't agree with them
no
why are they calling you homophobia or
homophobes yeah so the the the
definition like you mentioned it is a
fear right phobia
they use it uh whenever someone has uh
hatred for or prejudice against gay
people not even hatred bro you just
disagree with it no i mean that's how
they use it but then the the textbook
definition when you look it up is this
prejudice prejudice hatred for
uh gay people essentially or homosexuals
and the thing is you know you you can
disagree with someone and not hate them
i think the only people that cannot
disagree and not hate is is the people
of that community to be completely
honest because they it's unfortunate but
you know they make it their entire
personality so if you disagree with it
no that's their entire personality so
it's like you disagree with them their
existence and that's you know it seems
like to be the case that that's how they
see it unfortunately but it's um there
is a big big difference between
disagreeing with someone
and having a hatred or a hatred for
prejudice against them
subhanallah
next question
oh not a question but comment if we give
up on having kids we do not have the
next din
what can you tell a knowledgeable person
that says the more you pay attention to
this
the more it'll affect us
i mean it could be true you know if if
the more you're exposed to something the
more it will affect you regardless you
are a product of your surroundings so
certain extent you are affected by
everything bro honestly i i could see a
sad video on tick tock and feel
depressed for the next hour like you
know it's it's normal
um but that's not to say we shouldn't
you know
entertain discussions with these things
you know if the truth needs to be spoken
go speak it if you're a person who can't
kind of indulge in these conversations
without coming out completely and
utterly you know messed up or or
depressed or whatever it might be then
maybe you should have these
conversations but you do need you know
as allah even mentions the quran people
a group of people to arise and speak the
truth and so on and so forth
got you okay next question
uh if it writes i want to study islam in
egypt masha allah my mother doesn't
allow it though i'm 18 and given the
quran uh
is this surah 9 verse 122 he wrote nine
semicolon 122 that's how you write quran
verses and no one here in my area knows
islam properly is it it's basically
on me to go can i secretly go we're not
qualified for your father's bro go ask
yourself inshaallah inshaallah
mahdid right allows us again if you're
not scrolling back up do you feel like
therapy and medication is okay in islam
again we cannot give fathers bro yeah
writes do you think at some point we
might have to create muslim villages
far from the cities where we will be
able to raise our kids far from this
madness
let's talk to the king of living
off-grid
i mean bro i'm by no means
um
that's
that's a good question
again i i i don't i'm not against that i
think that would be really cool
i think it would be um
[Music]
a very different life
for the kids like upbringing them but
at some point or another they're going
to be exposed
and it's like
do you want to show to them and then
when it finally hits them like they just
really don't know how to handle it and
it's too much for them
or do you want to start to expose them
to it but be there
and like make sure that they can handle
that exposure
almost like exposure therapy like they
can handle that to where they can
finally stand on their own without being
um influenced
by these ex these exposures these things
that they're being exposed to
anything else
at that point um it's not really about
off-grid but it's about the children you
know there are and you fight probably
know this a lot better than me but there
are certain years when the children they
learn the most they grow the most and
they really start to
you know form their personality who they
are um so if you take these prime years
and really focus on teaching them what's
right i think it'll set inshaallah a
good foundation for when they do
eventually go to school to be able to
you know not really
fall into this
this agenda really and not fall into
these narratives and be
unfortunately very confused
um
mashallah
next question
sky x masks rates off topic fight what's
your workout routine i don't work out
bro it doesn't work i don't work out i
don't know why you guys thought it
worked out next question we are the only
ones that work out yeah that's it no
same person individual mashallah will
you guys bring hamza back on the podcast
inshallah he's willing to come back i
don't mind bro adonis adonis
adonis knows that to be a man means you
must come back on the three muslims
podcast
and and jeffrey doesn't do it because
he's a wuss but adonis knows and he and
he and he does what's difficult
listen we will only have him back on
this podcast
if he stretches
while we're live
stuck for a lot bro
ah
question and west writes wi-fi always
wearing hats and why you always wearing
hats
right did you guys move across the usa
together for this podcast we're in
undisclosed uh territory right now
technically international waters
subhanallah
next rami brother uzi writes do you
think nationalism destroyed islam which
started in ww1 or even before um
well actually there are many different
things that destroyed islam nationalism
i i would say is more so something that
happened post world war one when they
divided the countries and then they're
like you're lebanon you're jordan you're
syria you're iraq iran and so on and so
forth then the nationalism began but if
you look before that you can see you
know maybe sometime after the
renaissance period during the
renaissance period you could see the
downfall of the muslims they really
formed two maybe three different groups
people that are like we should adopt
everything from you know europe and the
west and then the people are like we
should adopt nothing from europe in the
west and maybe a very few people that
understood that we can take things like
technology and advancements believe
their culture and their beliefs and
stuff to them
so there was this huge disagreement i
would say at that time and as
the west europe and so on and so forth
started literally sending agents
agents yes yes this is not cia movie or
fbi movie the real life they sent agents
and we have their names
um i think muhammad abdul was one of
them a bunch of people sent agents to go
basically infiltrate the muslims start
teaching their
misconceptions of islam and so on and so
forth it divided the muslims even more
and europe got stronger and stronger and
stronger they sided with people in
africa people in the middle east
different groups uh during world war one
to get them to turn against the muslims
go against the ottomans and the rest is
literally history
they don't teach any of that stuff
i don't know bro i don't use an episode
one day maybe on an exclusive platform
don't know
brother i don't know
inshallah
what do you want i want to give a huge
shout out to only stunton for giving the
most broad question that we've ever
gotten in the last year and a half on
youtube
thoughts on miami what do you want to
know about that texting thoughts on
water
next question uh aside writes how should
i approach this topic with my younger
brother
should i introduce it to him directly
and teach him against it should i just
mention it or should i not mention it i
should mention he's homeschooled and
knows nothing of this
you should slowly start to
present this
and
you could be like oh
when you're in public have you seen
that there are some guys like holding
other guys hands or some woman holding
on the woman's hands and just ask him
like what he feels about that
what he thinks about it and then you go
from there
i think it depends on a lot of different
things how old is the kid what do they
know so far about not just about like
you know the community but more so about
gender and if he knows he's a boy and if
he knows what boys are and girls are in
the difference if there is one and you
have to gauge where he's at and like
brother ahana said just slowly slowly
introduce it to him and put him on the
right path inshallah
he about to write is there something as
integrated integrating
gays who identify as muslim into the
muslim community
um well i mean honestly it really
depends i think that is kind of a vague
definition and they're gay what do you
mean they're gay like they have an
attraction to other men or they believe
it's okay to act upon that attraction
other men i think let's go with the
latter yeah so if you're talking about
people who are gay identify as gay and
believe that it's okay to act upon these
things in islam this person very well
may not even be a muslim because they
would be taken out of the fault of islam
because they're disagreeing with the
quran and what the prophet allah taught
us about islam straight up yeah so that
person wouldn't be a muslim so in that
by those definitions you cannot have a
person who is gay and muslim you can
have a person who is attracted to the
same gender the same sex
maybe even if they've slipped once in
their life twice in their life that
doesn't take them out of islam as long
as they know it's sinful then they could
still be a muslim one hundred percent
feral rights we had the sound but yeah i
know if it all right how to find the
halal wife from your live chat
don't that was wrong what are you doing
bro you're coming here for knowledge or
you're coming here for i have the proper
intention you're probably messing around
but come on bro i'm some
[Music]
guys what is your favorite muslim leader
like sultan on caliph and your guys
favorite muslim empire
i've never thought about that to be
honest me neither but let's go um
islamic leader general just like in
general
expanded islam like no one else like no
one else he went to like the borders of
china subhanallah
from mecca man masha'allah that's
amazing um i'm gonna have to say
saludina
and i'll be pleased with him
he he said that uh you know
and i again i don't know if this is
i don't know but it's
well used in the dallas scene
so do your own research guys come on why
are you listening to layman and taking
what we say is legislative authority
come on now but
if you want to corrupt a generation make
adultery and fornication i believe
very common amongst the youth
he said this hundreds of years ago bro
yeah
i can't say i have a favorite muslim
leader
like a sultan or caliph
because we got another ep
that we're about to record
and then we about to get ourselves
some food
[Music]
inshallah yeah we got one more episode
we gotta record after this guys but
please stay tuned for july 1st inshallah
next friday uh we need you guys we need
your support for the the premiere to
share the video uh that airs this this
one obviously but share the video next
friday with your loved ones watch the
entire video guys give us that watch
time and retention time uh and insha
allah you guys will be satisfied with
the podcast should we give them the
topic or keep it a surprise just keep it
guys surprised
okay
sounds good
uh let's see
we'll do two more questions and then
we'll be done
uh vladimir writes what is nofap and
what are its benefits i'm going to speak
on behalf of ango he's not going to
answer this because this is come on bro
that's like
after this point if you haven't learned
something about nofap from unhealth
are you even listening bro subhanallah
hamza writes what is the best way to get
over regret and guilt from the past
[Music]
and allah does as he wills you know this
is the decree of allah allah that he
wills of
there's a beautiful hadith and i think i
actually mentioned in the recording we
did so you have to wait till july 1st
for that one but just to summarize he
says at the end of the hadith sallallahu
i do not say if
don't say if only i did this or that
then you know this would have happened
instead rather say this is the decree of
allah and allah does as he will so same
thing here don't regret it ask for
forgiveness whatever it is um you know
make dua for allah to make you better
try make yourself better and move on if
you let the past hold you then
inshaallah you will you know you may
never progress in the future
all right
last one
brother or sister ahmath writes gabriel
romani in the podcast on july 2nd first
of all i don't think i've ever said
there's a podcast july 2nd and a month
is slick because they they corrected it
to july first email bless you um
well we'll say this cannot say anything
no
because we already filmed the episode
with july 1st and if gabriel just said
he landed how is that even possible but
if y'all can get this video to a
thousand likes
within a week
right
inshallah we'll try to see what we could
do how about that
fair enough thousand likes
like this video insha allah
um sister sally writes martial army
wiser than his age alhamdulillah
may allah allow us to be as you see us
i mean
okay
with that being said guys
please
do not
bow the knee
to the dominant ideology
of
alphabetization
of our young
men and women that have fitrah
alhamdulillah
and do not change your ways
to appeal to the masses
rather
straight to allah say say it again bro i
said rather prosperity to allah
um
[Music]
you